too long not enough knuckles too much
knuckles generic franchise cash grab or
full throttle family adventure the
critics have seen the sonic sequel
here's what they're saying when fans got
their first look at the sonic the
hedgehog movie back in 2019 there was an
uproar over the blue speedster's design
which tried to make the legendary video
game character look a little too human
uh
meow
paramount quickly rushed to redesign the
iconic hedgehog but it seemed like the
project might have been doomed before
its release thankfully that wasn't the
case and the film eventually managed to
win audiences over raking in 319 million
dollars worldwide it was more than
enough for the studio to greenlight a
sequel which started production in 2021
and now it's finally almost here the
first trailer for the sequel revealed
that sonic is joined by tails this time
around as they go up against the
sinister doctor robotnik and his new
henchman knuckles echidna the first
reactions from critics have now arrived
online ahead of the movie's april 8th
release date and they seem to be
impressed with the sequel for the most
part although the first reviews for
sonic the hedgehog 2 have featured their
fair share of criticism it disappeared
that for the most part critics
appreciate the sequel for its fun
atmosphere and new characters the radio
times patrick ramona wrote ben schwartz
gives another perky vocal performance in
the role full of warmth and humor while
colin o'shaughnessy makes a successful
transition from video games to film as
tales meanwhile game radar's bradley
russell found idris elba's knuckles to
be a worthy addition to the series he
wrote the bristling echidna's
hard-hitting approach is welcome
providing a far more physical threat for
sonic here than anything found in the
original movie however russell did also
criticize the sequel for being too
similar to the first film writing the
story beats here follow the same
well-worn path as the 2020 film with
robotnik's mad schemes and the power of
friendship message feeling it touched
reheated a second time around meanwhile
sean keane of cnet praised the movie for
capturing the sense of adventure fans
might remember from their childhoods he
also singled out the visual effects
adding every sequence focusing on sonic
and pals is so visually delightful and
thoroughly dazzling however not everyone
was quite as impressed with the movie
writing for variety peter de bruge
argued that the sequel takes what was
endearing about the original and renders
it generic in a hurry he went on to
criticize the movie's long runtime
writing an hour and a half would have
been a perfectly fine run time whereas
at 2 hours and change sonic 2 wears out
its welcome well before it turns into
yet another phonetin franchise entry the
early reactions from critics suggest
that paramount has a success on its
hands with sonic the hedgehog 2.
although whether it will be the original
film's box office haul remains to be
seen fans clearly love the first film as
it has a 93 audience score on rotten
tomatoes so families may well flock to
theaters on opening weekend the mostly
positive early reactions will also
likely reassure the studio that the
money has been a worthy investment this
will be welcome news to paramount of
course who has already given the green
light for sonic the hedgehog 3. that
announcement arrived back in february
2022 alongside the news that a spin-off
series focused on idris elba's knuckles
is also in development for paramount
plus the live-action show is clearly the
first step in expanding the sonic the
hedgehog franchise and it'll be
interesting to see whether other
characters will get their own shows
further down the line producer neil h
moritz spoke a deadline about the third
sequel and the spin-off saying the sky
is truly the limit and i am immensely
proud to be part of creating new sonic
content for longtime fans as well as
introducing sonic to a new generation so
where might the third movie go plot wise
well there are plenty of other heroes
anti-heroes and villains in a sonic
world who could easily feature in the
movie and many of them might even be
able to carry their own projects but
however the franchise plays out in the
future based on the early reviews for
sonic the hedgehog 2 it looks like sonic
is here to stay
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]